Joker​ is dividing the heck out of audiences
far and wide, including one very significant
crowd: Oscar voters.
​The Hollywood Reporter​ recently spoke
with a number of members of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences, and like
critics and audiences, they were largely split
on the film.
First, let's hear from the crowd that loved
it.
One male member of the Members at Large Branch
who saw the film at the official Academy screening
noted that the flick was well-received by
the 500 audience members, and said,
"I think it's brilliant.
Joaquin Phoenix has never been better.
[...] I thought that the [director of photography],
production designer and others created the
look and feel of the period really well, and
the fact that it has very contemporary themes
of economic/class inequities felt just right.
Overall, a home run."
A female member of the same branch agreed,
although she admitted that her, quote, "stomach
was still churning" the day after viewing
the film.
She added,
"It made me uncomfortable from the very first
frame to the last, but I thought the movie
was extraordinary.
It's the most outstanding performance I've
seen in many years [...] It's still early,
but I can certainly see myself nominating
it for best picture.
And [Phoenix] has to get nominated, or the
actors branch doesn't know what it's doing."
A male member of the writers' branch compared
the film favorably to the last picture to
score an Oscar win for an actor portraying
the Joker, saying,
"I thought the filmmaking was exceptional
certainly the most innovative superhero movie
since The Dark Knight.
[...] I haven't seen any of this season's
'Academy' movies yet, but, artistically, I
think this film is stronger than many of last
year's Oscar-nominated films."
Then there was one male member of the producers'
branch who boldly predicted that Joker will
deliver come February, saying,
"I loved it and it will win Best Picture.
I am really bored with all the superhero movies,
but here I really liked it because it's a
great movie before it's a genre movie."
To say that many of the Oscar voters who spoke
with The Hollywood Reporter were not quite
so impressed would be a massive understatement.
Those who disliked the film disliked it intensely,
and they didn't hold back when discussing
what they perceived to be Joker's faults.
One female member of the executive branch,
while praising Phoenix's work, simply couldn't
puzzle out the point of the movie.
She said,
"Strange, depressing film.
I was vaguely mesmerized, but… to what end?
I found it severely lacking any specific thematic
point.
Great performance and impressive filmmaking,
but a rather unpleasant experience overall."
One male member of the directors' branch called
the flick a "cynical mess," one that was not
so much influenced by the works of Martin
Scorsese as it was derivative of his works.
He said,
"I also found it to be more than a bit irresponsible,
in terms of its depiction of both mental illness
and violence.
[...] It also seems the film was made only
to provoke.
But I find it isn't interesting enough to
do that.
Subtlety is not the director or lead actor's
strong suit here.
[...] Finally, I found the film to be a big
disappointment… and one filled with self-importance."
A male member of the documentary branch stated
that while the film was admittedly well-made,
he found it to be downright irresponsible
of the filmmakers to unleash it upon a world
in which unhinged, male loners seemingly perpetrate
violence every other day.
He said,
"Who knows what effect it will have on some
deranged sociopath in today's climate of gun
violence?
[...] Bottom line: technically an interestingly
experimental genre film that presents a socially
dicey spectacle that I found personally repugnant."
Although most Oscar voters' opinions came
down firmly on one side of the fence or the
other, there was a distinct minority that
fell into the "undecided" camp.
One male member of the producers' branch was
befuddled as to how he should vote, even though
he personally loved the film.
He explained,
"I don't see any reason why this movie should
be out in the universe.
There is nothing in it that starts a conversation
it just pours lighter fluid on a conversation
that's staring us in the face every week.
[...] I don't know if it should be banned
or it should be given every award!"
Another male member of the same branch was
blown away by the film's technical merits,
but nevertheless found it literally too difficult
to watch due to its subject matter, saying,
"I found the craft to be stunning on every
level beautiful photography, design, costumes.
But I deeply despise the movie.
[...] We had to drink away our discomfort.
[...] It was the first movie in history that
was too dark for me."
Based on all of these comments, it seems like
Joker has roughly a 50/50 chance of scoring
an Oscar win, and its strongest chance seems
to be in the Best Actor category.
With a good number of Oscar voters on its
side, though, it's possible that the flick
could score nominations for its direction
and cinematography, for which its has received
pretty consistent praise.
It could even buck the odds to score a Best
Picture nomination, and if it does, it's not
outside the realm of possibility that it could
win; at the moment, one online odds maker
has the flick dead even with Scorsese's The
Irishman as the favorites to take home the
big prize, according to Bleeding Cool.
Perhaps Joker really will get the last laugh
at the 91st Academy Awards ceremony, which
takes place on February 9th, 2020.
"Ah ha ha ha ha."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.